Here is the method that you were asked to complete. We have an array of objects
that are measurable. And we now should sum up all of the measures and then take
the average. So over here, objects is an array of measurables. We need to give
a type for each of its elements. While that type is measurable. Next we need to
compute the sum of the measures. What method should we call an obj? We only
have one choice. Obj is a measurable, and a measurable has only a single method
called get measure. So let's call it. And here it is, our universal algorithm
for computing averages. You'll never again have to write it, provided, of
course, that the classes that you want to put in are willing to implement the
measurable interfaces.